-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
Happy New Year, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Saturday was New Year's Day.
As to what year,
it's anyone's guess.
[ Laughter ]
Eric Adams was sworn in
as the mayor of New York City
shortly after midnight
on New Year's Eve
in Times Square.
It was a nice gesture
to let Mayor de Blasio
drop the ball one last time.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
That's right, Eric Adams was
sworn in on Saturday
as New York City's 110th mayor.
Wow, just think!
One day, he, too,
might never be president.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke yesterday
with Ukrainian
President Zelensky
and said that the U.S.
and its allies will
"respond decisively if Russia
further invades Ukraine,"
which is sort of like
your parents threatening
to ground you, if they find
any more crack
in your sock drawer.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
announced recently
that the government
would provide Americans
with 500 million free
rapid coronavirus tests.
And, to save time,
they come pre-positive.
[ Laughter ]
That way, you don't have to wait
the 15 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the U.S. is averaging more
than 386,000 new cases
of the coronavirus each day.
Wow, that's crazy --
386,000 people managed
to get tested?
[ Laughter ]
The CDC announced recently
that it has shortened
the recommended time
that people quarantine
after testing positive
for the coronavirus,
from 10 days to 5 days.
They added that today is
basically over,
so, it's really four days.
Plus, Sundays don't count,
so three day--
You know what?
Just take the weekend.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You'll be fine.
Tesla has issued a recall
for nearly 500,000 cars,
due to two separate defects.
No word on whether Time magazine
is also planning
to issue a recall.
[ Laughter ]
Just 12 days
after it was released,
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
has made over $1 billion
[ Cheering and applause ]
and three --
three new variants.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
Papa John's recently added
a New York-style pizza
to its menu that features
eight large slices
that customers can fold to eat.
But, hey, unless you can
drunkenly pay for it
with a Ziploc bag full
of nickels
and then fall asleep eating it
on the subway,
it's not New York-style.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
authorities in Florida
recently arrested a man
during a traffic stop,
when they allegedly found
cocaine and crystal meth wrapped
around his penis,
or, as it's known there,
a Jacksonville condom.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
And that was the monologue.
It's nice.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You know it's nice.
You want to like
start off the year
with some insane news
out of Florida
and that was just really nice
of that gentleman
to wrap his penis
in crystal meth.
[ Laughter ]